welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Boss and this is an explanation of the
ending and post-credits scene of Black
Adam in which the hierarchy of
Powers kinda changes spoiler warning for
anyone who's managed to avoid what
happens at the end of this movie in this
video I'm gonna break down that full
hierarchy and what it'll look like in
the future now that Walter Ramada isn't
at the top of it anymore also did The
Rock kidnap him is that what he meant by
the hierarchy power will change I just
hope no one got hurt
so in the Final Act of this movie The
resurrected Black Adam or teth Adam is
revealed that he wasn't the true
champion of conduct that was his son who
root who is worthy kid whom the Wizards
gave Shazam Powers powering up this kid
into a champion form played by Uli
latsukampu the Australian Tongan actor
who plays Dwayne Johnson in the NBC
series young Rock really perfect casting
there but heroot ends up killed by the
king octon's Archer after Haru
transferred his powers to his father so
Adam Slaughters the kingsman and was
imprisoned by the Wizards of Shazam who
deemed him unworthy until he was awoken
5000 years later in the events of this
film so the Justice Society of America
JSA composed of Hawkman Dr Fate cyclone
and Adam Smasher realized alongside
Adriana that the crown of Sabah
inscription actually translates to only
death can lead to life and getting Black
Adam to kill him was all part of
ishmael's plan Ishmael is the descendant
of King akhtan which we all should have
seen because he was played by the same
actor his soul travels to the rock of
finality the hellish mirror realm to the
rock of Eternity where he becomes the
champion of the dead and resurrects is
the demon sabak the JSA fights to stop
him from reaching the throne on conduct
Dr vate averts the Fate that resulted in
hawkman's death by facing sabak alone
using duplicates of himself while Astro
projecting himself back to the
de-powered atom imprisoned in Waller's
black site overseen by Amelia Harcourt
Jennifer Holland from Suicide Squad and
Peacemaker making a quick Cameo earlier
in the film zabach makes it to the
throne and spawns allegiance of the Dead
to fight the people of conduct Adam
floats to the surface says Shazam and
helps the others fight zabach until Adam
rips him in half uttering Emma's
suggested catchphrase tell them the man
in Black sent you Adam destroys the
throne and says the people of conduct do
not need a hero they have plenty of
Heroes but he'll stick around as a
protector and that brings us to the big
post-credits scene a drone floats down
to the ruins of conduct where Amanda
Waller's hologram speaks to Black Adam
she says okay Black Adam my name is
Amanda Waller congratulations you have
my attention this is going to be your
only warning you don't want to stay in
my prison that's fine conduct is your
prison now you step one foot outside of
it you will not live to regret it during
this the camera frames Adam's hand in
the Gunslinger pose calling back him
reenacting the Clint Eastwood western
earlier Black Adam says there's no one
on this planet that can stop me Waller
says I can call in a favor and send
people who aren't from this planet Black
Adam says send them all Waller says As
You Wish Black Adam zaps the Drone
blowing it up and we hear a sonic boom
overhead and in the smoke a caped Shadow
descends and a familiar voice says it's
been a while since anyone has made the
world this nervous and Henry cavill's
Superman steps forward in his classic
red and blue suit perfect single curl of
hair in the style of Christopher Reeve
the notes of John Williams Superman
theme play underneath if Superman says
Black Adam we should talk so while the
hierarchy of the DC Universe didn't
exactly change yet it's now clear that
this was some bullish marketing by The
Rock cutting promos like he did in his
pro wrestling days but really to wrestle
control of the direction of the DCU
going forward seems like he was
successful it's fascinating to hear the
story behind the scenes that led to this
because ahead of the release Johnson
made it evidently clear that Superman
was gonna cameo in this and really that
it was his hope for the franchise to set
up a match between Black Adam and
Superman if it were me and if I were in
prison for 5 000 years I'd want to hit
the ground running and get myself an
official title if you want to be
addressed as Lord or lady established
titles can make it official established
titles is a Project based on a historic
Scottish custom where landowners are
referenced to as lairds or Lords and
Ladies in English they let people buy as
little as one square foot of dedicated
land so they can call themselves The
Lord or lady in return to established
titles commits to planting a tree it's a
fun way to help preserve the beautiful
woodlands and biodiversity of Scotland
while raising funds to support Global
conservation efforts established titles
work with global charity trees for the
future and one tree planted to help them
plan a tree for every order Plus for
those with Scottish Heritage it's a
great way to connect to your family
Roots as a bonus established titles told
us that the first 200 people purchasing
a title pack using our link will
effectively be next to each other within
a few minutes of walking distance
depending on how many of you want to
become a learner lady we could buy our
own little new Rockstar's Kingdom so
your title packs give you a numbered
plot of dedicated land on a private
estate in edelston and the official
certificate with a crest
you can even change your name on credit
cards blame tickets and dating profiles
with their new title you can get a
couple pack for you and your partner
with the joining plots of land you can
literally have this gift ready in five
minutes it makes for an amazing last
minute gift established titles is
actually running an early Black Friday
right now if you use the code rockstars
you get an additional 10 off so go to
establishtitles.com new rockstars to get
your gifts now and help support the
channel he either intentionally or
unintentionally borrowed from the
Playbook of Warner's other big franchise
the monsterverse which pitted Titans
against each other in Godzilla vs Kong
in 2021 which was a massive hit for the
studio with HBO Max Black Adam in this
movie is a figure pretty similar to
Kaiju like Godzilla in Kong he's an
amoral protector resurrected from the
ancient world by power hungry modern
humans he smashes everything he forms a
connection with a kid and the humans of
the story have to awaken this monster to
free him from captivity to fight another
monster in the final battle Dwayne
Johnson confirmed a Cinema Blend two
weeks before the release that's setting
up a fight between Black Adam and Kal-El
was the whole point of this to launch a
new air the DC Universe to step up as
the guy who's listening to the fans and
really he's using his experiences from
his pro wrestling days and this week The
Hollywood Reporter confirmed that
outgoing head of DC films Walter Hamada
now stepping away initially fought
against the idea of bringing Henry
Cavill back into the franchise but
Johnson went over his head to warn her
heads Michael Deluca and Pam Abdi who
have long wanted to reprise the caval
version of Superman and they approved it
this led to a furious round of
negotiations around Labor Day and
reshoots were done as recently as
mid-september with Henry Cavill the
whole recentness of this is likely why
there was no Henry Cavill Superman news
at Comic-Con in July but throughout
October suddenly Dwayne Johnson has been
cutting his Superman promos so this
Hollywood Reporter article says that
Deluca and Abdi want to do a Man of
Steel too with Henry Cavill that project
being produced by Charles rovin and
they're looking at a list of writers to
do it including Christopher mcgorry who
worked with Henry Cavill and Mission
Impossible Fallout this guy is one of my
favorite writers in the industry and I
think he would do an amazing job with it
so will this man fan of Steel 2 film ba
Superman vs Blackout movie or will they
be separate films I am assuming that
they're going to be separate films
because these Man of Steel 2 plants have
been in the minds of Warner Brothers
heads for a while now there's really
Walter Hamada who wanted to push the
franchise away from the Zack Snyder era
but when you watch this Black Adam film
the visual style is all rooted in
Snyder's style the use of slow motion
action the way Black Adam hovers like a
Kryptonian ancient world flashbacks in
the style of 300 an epically violent
finish him kill while I don't think
future films in the DC franchise will
firmly pick a side on which continuity
of Justice League the DC EU is going to
continue forward in the theatrical
release or the Snyder cut but I think in
spirit and in casting they will maintain
Snyder's Vision with Henry Cavill as
Superman here he's no longer in the
black suit that he was wearing at the
end of the Snyder cut but remember he
did have plenty of other backup red blue
suits on that Kryptonian ship really I'm
interested the fact that he was right
there the moment Black Adam Zapped
Amanda Waller's drone suggesting that
Superman and Amanda Waller might have
some kind of arrangement remember in
that wide shot of the black site we saw
dozens of metahumans in suspended
animation and I think Halal was the one
who helped while around all of them up
all of these questions can be answered
in a second Man of Steel film starring
Henry Cavill and I'm so pumped that he's
back and then on the other side of that
film waiting for him will be Black Adam
I think we're all ready to see it I'm
gonna do a full Easter egg breakdown of
this film it's gonna come out on the
channel on Monday in the meantime you
can follow me on Tick Tock Instagram and
Twitter at eavos follow new Rockstar
subscribe to new rockstars for more
analysis of everything you love thanks
for watching bye
[Music]
thank you